i will call the work session together on
sp412
can we all just have henry start off
with an explanation or the other of you
have
okay henry why don't you come up and
have at it
should say mr lipman my apologies
director director lipman
thank you mr chairman
the record henry lipman the medicaid
director
i think i would like to start
sort of at the very top
that
included in the budget
in every year is a lump sum amount
to cover
nursing home nursing facility costs
and
historically
there's also
a
you may have heard another context a
factor that the department of the the
total budget amount
does not necessarily equate to
a five percent rate increase and that's
what i want to
explain um
in my
discussion here with you
um
at it at a global level on the
the amount
that is available to
to to fund services right uh date
patient days in the nursing facility
is a function of the total budget that
we're allowed to work with in this case
whatever was originally plus the five
percent
and the number of days that we expect to
pay for
you may recall i believe it was an hp
one that originally 3 900 was the number
of days
and i
bed bed days
days that we'd be
bed days that we'd be
paying for
over the course every day for the course
of a year is effectively what that
as you're also aware because many of you
work on county level things that county
nursing homes and other nursing homes
have had a decrease in the number of
days
um due to
covert and related things
staffing shortages and what have you
and so um
well i think the
this was the first time i'm aware of
that in the budget
documents that a prescribed number of
days was
was included in there um and
and so in setting the rates
um which on a facility level vary based
on the acuity meaning the intensity of
service
um that they have and the the um
their costs so
if you kind of think about it in a
personal level you know we're dealing
with inflation now right just on a
personal level inflation's eight and a
half percent if you get a an increase a
in medicare um of six percent you know
that you're actually going to lose
spending power in much the same way the
the nursing facilities if their expenses
go up
and um they could potentially even
though they're getting more money
result in a lower rate because their
expenses are increasing higher than the
amount of money that we're putting in
but
so what
ended up happening um very early on
well sort of when you said the rate
would go down the relative rate would
but the
the absolute rate
was only impacted by the bed days not by
the inflation rate correct correct i was
just using inflation as a
as as sort of a comparison something
that people could maybe connect in their
personal life that okay you know if
inflation goes up more than your your
salary then you end up losing spending
power
similarly um and you said something else
for the first time
we put in a bad day
in the budget so that was probably a
mistake on our part
i think i'll look to
kevin if he has a different perspective
on that but i think that we also got an
opinion that we could deviate from that
based on what we were observing and so
we reset the rates based on a more
current experience in
i believe october which led
the rate increase when we just used the
3900 was around 1.6 percent
and then when we were able to reset it
based on um
more
current but still i think lagging behind
what was happening number we were able
to get the rate up to 3.6
and then
we did another rate setting in january
which we would ordinarily do
and the rate got up to uh five percent
um actually a little bit up above five
percent
i think um senator rosenwald and um
what um
senator gotta senator geider both were
on top of us real quickly in terms of
you know they were hearing from
constituents this wasn't what was
intended in the budget and so um
you know i think they try to fashion
something where
um
you know there would be potentially if
needed to so that the full
year of 22 in the full year of 23 would
support you know the 5
increase which i think was the intent of
the legislators in terms of putting five
percent more in i think there's a what
wasn't i think transparent is that
there's a whole state plan
methodology that depends on
the individual facilities cost and their
their acuity as well
but so
the way
nursing facilities are ultimately
reimbursed is that
the
legislation in this year and other years
says anything that's left in the account
at the end of the year gets paid back
out pro rata based on patient days
so it looks like um you know we're at
five percent now but i think the in the
senate the perspective was we want the
five percent to at least
be in effect for the entire year we've
also identified that
you know there's some risk in 23 if um
you know the
the coveted situation and the labor
situation turns around that we could
also see
you know patient activity go up again
number of patient days
that we could find ourselves short and
23.
so i think the idea in the legislation
was
to have the 5 million as a contingency
if need be to make sure that the 5
percent was delivered
and if it wasn't if it wasn't needed
then it would lapse back into um the
general fund and if you can correct me
um i think the i guess the only thing i
would comment on is whether
you think that
say you get the five million dollar
appropriation authorized by this bill
whether you think that any unspent
amount would go back into the general
fund or whether you think the footnote
on 2152 would apply that says any
unspent amount or goes back to the
nursing homes at the end of the year i'm
i'm not really clear on that myself
i guess the way i've interpreted it is
that we would only tap into that five
million to the extent that it was needed
to deliver the five percent and
otherwise it would lapse
unlike the 504 account with laps back to
the general fund i think that was
the senator's intent in introducing that
and one other question
and that's to imply to apply not just
through this fiscal year but also
okay
so question you you said in january you
we calculated and you hit five percent
so had you used those same
parameters back in
july last year you would hit the five
percent right then correct right if you
remember though like we've gone through
waves if this seems to be over and then
it's then it's not or we're going to
recover
in terms of
healthcare activity and then it hasn't
and i think what we're seeing now is it
seems to be you know the the workforce
shortage is maybe a larger factor than
even any
um particular public health issue if you
will
so
how do you read this bill that there
should be
immediate of this passes that there
should be immediate payment to make up
for the last whereas whatever it's been
since july and then applying the five
percent going forward or that we apply
the five percent going forward and see
if we run out of money by the end of
next year
so i i i see it as
um we have plot i think you look at you
have to look at this on an on a
annual basis because of the 504 account
provision where any leftover amount
gets passed back
so the way i look at it is do we achieve
five percent for the full
22 if we have
um
the
then then we wouldn't use any of it and
if it went into 23 and we were short of
being able to sustain that rate then we
would
okay but we're not going to get we
wouldn't hit the 405 for the full year
if we're only at five percent now we
don't go up or by misunderstanding yeah
i i think that the from correct in terms
of how the 504 account flows is that at
the end of each year
we um
this is christy roy who actually does
the work behind the scenes here
um
due to the fact that utilization is so
low
due to the fact that the utilization has
decreased so much
the remainder in that 504 account
we're
assuming for the remainder of this year
could be enough
to sustain the five percent for the full
year so if we calculated the average
rate for all the nursing facilities at
the utilization that they're actually at
rather than what the forecasted
utilization was back when we calculated
the rates at the beginning of the fiscal
year
it would be five percent does that is
that clear
it is if
you're expecting that there'll be a
greater payout in the final few months
here so that the average works out is
that kind of what you're trying to say
yes so at the remainder
of at the close of the fiscal year
whatever remains in that 504 account
will be paid out we could expect that
figure
for you know for the last four months we
would expect that figure
could be
enough to cover five percent as an
average
for all of the nursing facilities okay
not facility specific five percent but
on average and and that doesn't require
any funds from this bill were to become
law for this year for this year and then
for the year or just for the last few
months five percent on average for the
full year we're currently at five
percent now
um or over just over five percent an
increase of where we were and as of june
now but we're talking about for the full
year
but that's only for this year not for
okay just because you're not aware of
what potential average bed counts that
sort of thing will be correct
and right and cost reports um and acuity
so there's there's multiple figures in
there okay
but i'm guessing that you have some
feeling for how that varies over time
we we
we generally do but um there's
definitely been challenges with coped
i mean where we were always around the
4100 when that i think when that
original 3 900 was put in it was a
relief because you know
the facility saw it as a relief however
when we were trending at 3600 it became
a hindrance so
we had always had the flexibility to use
actual figures as they were trending
and that challenged
us so it sounds like you think perhaps
bed council go up in the next year
i think the industry folks here probably
have a better feel for us but
um you know that that is i think a
possibility none of us have been
predicting utilization very well in this
environment
but
the way i kind of look at it is
we're trying to meet the legislative
intent
of what was passed which is to provide
an average increase of 5 percent i think
we'll be able to do it based on what
we're seeing so far this year um 23 is a
question mark i think when the
legislation was introduced by the
senator to begin with it was less
certain that we'd hit five percent
because we were only at 1.66 and then
three points something and until getting
another look at it
i think you know the
maybe the larger picture that i wasn't
here for the earlier meeting and i
apologize i wasn't able to make it but
you know i think the nursing
facility sector with wage costs and
everything's under a lot of pressure
i think what we're addressing here is
whether the five percent can be achieved
or not i think there may be other
arguments that that it needs to be more
for other reasons um but we just want to
be
testified to the bill specifically so to
stay in the four corners
the other questions
robson walnut so i i just want to be
clear i just want to for myself be clear
so
for this year
you uh would not need to use
you and are not anticipating that you
have to use any of the five million
that's in this
correct bill okay so you have enough
to do the five percent
and
not use
this but it's in 20 the next fiscal year
that you anticipate that you'll need the
five million in order to continue
the five percent right and the reason is
because the
going from 4 100 to 3 900 to now about 3
600 i think we're at somewhere in that
neighborhood um that gives us confidence
if that were to spring back um then
that's where we might we wouldn't
necessarily have enough money to to
cover that five percent and that's most
likely now to play out in 23 based on
excuse me i think maybe i misspoke but
no yeah it originally
originally the bed days
we had started and we had been using
and then there was a bed day factor put
in to one of the house bills that was 3
um and that was what caused the
challenge and where we were actually at
at that time was around 3 600 i believe
and then when we readjusted in october
we were down to i think we ended up
utilizing a 35 something for the figure
so
and where are you now
or january when you did your last 35
yeah that's i think we used around 3 500
and there are certain days that we do
remove from that factor like atypical
thank you mr chair and this is probably
actually for the committee
on line 11
it there's a sentence that says the
department may accept and expend
matching federal funds without prior
approval of the fiscal committee is that
standard practice or is that
is that an exception to our general
policy
that's been standard
standard practice in many cases where
you have a standalone bill that
appropriates general funds that may also
come with federal funds because in the
budget you're actually appropriating the
federal funds themselves so the
department has no reason to go to fiscal
um
in this case you're not making that
appropriation clear so you're just
allowing the department the authority to
spend those funds without having to go
all right and
thanks for that and then the second
question um
should should we specific
specify whether this these funds lapse
you could i think
i think the explanation that henry gave
makes sense to me um i think if you
wanted to be crystal clear you could add
a line in here saying that any unspent
funds appropriated
as a result of this 5 million will lapse
at the end of the biennium
thank you very much both of you i
appreciate it we'll hang around if you
oh we'll go ahead so so mr lippman uh
i i i didn't have any more questions
about the bill but i but i uh i wonder
did you get word um
holly heather
heidi
happy i forget your first name i'm sorry
brooke
i'm i'm not even close
miss belanger thank you
did you get word that um
i i would really appreciate a
written
document of exactly what went wrong and
and what
uh i and i and if it were oriented
towards um teaching future division
three people you know how we made this
mistake so that we don't do it again
that would be great i'd be happy to put
something together i had to sort of put
that together to explain it to the
senators when they were looking at the
bills i have something already sort of
started on that but the simplest thing
to remember about
nursing facilities if you're up against
this is that five percent added to the
budget doesn't necessarily translate to
a five percent rate increase because of
how
costs at facilities or their acuities
change but and i think it was you know
in talking to karen rounds um
i think that uh
it's that was at the sort of the tail
end of of uh
the committee of conference where
um
you know i think it was decided based on
input you were getting to to make a
change and i think it just happened
without the chance to sort of take it
back to the department and run some
calculations i think
similar to the benefit of a fiscal note
it's
you know you can test your assumption as
to what you're going on so i guess those
are the two things but i'm happy to
write it up and and submit it to you if
that's all the committee and the
objective there would also just be tell
us how to how to do it that's right well
i mean you we now we know how to do it
wrong you know if you could just tell us
how to do it right that would be
great also is it possible to see a
spreadsheet that shows the formula that
you use based on that day's acuity and
all those kinds of things just get a
feel for
how that actually all
we have definitely documents but
a spreadsheet would be a little bit
challenging but i have documents that we
can show that walks through the whole
process it's all written in our state
plan
um and it's
it's a little bit complicated because it
depends on like costs and cost reports
but yeah we definitely have documents
that can walk you through the whole
thing
that we already have prepared that we
you know can't do the general public or
new nursing facility administrators do
they include something like an equation
for
not the date not the total
days and calculating
the rates but yes and we have um
committee members and like a committee
that we go through first so absolutely
what might be helpful if we could do
something um one-on-one like we did with
the actuarial studies
we could show you that all that details
because some of it's proprietary for
and and then also um
okay so it's practically april 15th
and i i was unaware of this problem that
has been happening since july
uh
and i would just ask you in the future
if we've broken something and you guys
need help
that uh i'd hate to i hate being the
last person to hear about it i have
three people on my committee on this
bill as co-sponsors
and i didn't even know we had a problem
so we have a breakdown in communication
i think
message heard and we'll do a better job
thank you director
is there anybody else would like to
uh jim monahan with the dupont group for
the new hampshire association of
counties i think henry explained much
better than i did or could have but i
did want to i did say i would come back
and report i know representative
leishman isn't here so but i think
the question about you know is it
retroactive and how would that pick
salaries was answered by henry when he
effectively said
as we stand today the five percent rate
increase has occurred
the concern is only will you have
funds in the budget for next year to
continue it so i think that answers the
question about whether
you know it is um
uh
recto active in
nature uh when it came to any sort of
salary increases things like that and
then finally just on this question of
uh we the counties were strong advocates
of putting the bed count in the budget
as you may recall part of that was
because the governor's budget had an 18
increase in the county cap
and one of the ways to reduce that was
to have the committee determine how many
bed days is that based on so going from
4 100 to 3 900 in the budget allowed us
to begin to push the county cap down and
that was the reason we did it so or
advocated
so for future reference when you're
dealing with us remind us to put in an
exception so that we get the number in
there correctly but then we tell them
not to use it in an appropriate way
well that's what you've got kevin ripple
for yeah okay
thank you
thank you very much appreciate
it else have any questions for mr
monahan
others in the
audience
yeah come on up
i don't recall your name so please
remind me
thank you mr chair uh for the record
brendan williams president of the new
hampshire healthcare association and uh
just reiterating our support for this
legislation i think for the reasons that
uh director lipman outlined ensuring
that the money exists
for the next fiscal year
to fund this increase
you know particularly given that the
increase itself
is still going to fall very short of
meeting the costs associated with this
pandemic and so
uh we still regard this as a critical
piece of legislation and encourage your
support
thank you
mr lippman can i ask you another
question
this is a broader much broader question
um but it ties in with the point that we
just made about and you made as well
that the nursing home costs have gone up
and
they're being squeezed sitting on the
fiscal committee i noticed a lot of
funding coming through for a variety of
things specifically geared towards
nursing homes strike teams enhanced
payments and that sort of thing can you
quantify
how
much
funding of that type has come through to
to assist nursing homes on top of what
was
budgeted last last year
i i'm sure the department could i think
karen rounds prepared something for um
government council similar to that
question i mean i think there's been
stuff that's come through the state um
through state control of federal funds
that have been and then there's funds
that came directly from
cms to facilities
um
here's sort of the the catch 22 of some
of this for example um
you're familiar with the probably the
mqip
tax that is paid and
so one of the things that and you're
also familiar with pro share right
how some of these things can work
against each other but like so the state
received an extra 6.2 percent during
prior period
and we passed that on directly to
nursing facilities as as payment
the way the pro share methodology works
they look at payment against costs so if
payments go up as a result of that 6.2
percent pro share gets pushed down a bit
um and so there's
it's a lot of hydraulics here in behind
how
the ultimate rates get set but
um
so you know they may
we increase the facility rate depending
on how costs go it could have
i think we're talking about in this
particular rate increase costs have
certainly gone up at least five percent
but if they didn't you know if you then
you run the risk that you're pro share
but the counties could go down as well
to some degree so it's
so is it hard to quantify
it's not hard to quantify when you have
the all the numbers in and can run the
calculations it's pretty um that's what
christy does for us um and i think we've
shared spreadsheets with you before for
hillsboro county but um it's hard to
anticipate in advance because we
facilities prepare their cost report
after the close of a fiscal year so you
know if they're doing
if they're being audited it may be three
months past the close of a fiscal year
before they truly know how their costs
are going to go and then
depending on
the share of medicaid patients treated
by the facility costs may get allocated
one way or another so in a year where
medicaid is more predominant there's
more costs to be able to be paid for
under medicaid but if another year
private pay is is is a higher percentage
then
then they could lose medicaid
reimbursement that way
so looking backward would be able to see
what that looked like for
not this fiscal year but 21.
i mean we do all those calculations
again i think uh
it's something that we could walk
through with you to okay to help it
provide some background on it and just
be able to understand you know what the
balance is there um across the board of
with all that's been flowing in and out
of the state one of the things i'm as
out of concern
with where the
nursing homes our nursing facilities are
trying to deal with the labor costs
and through our state
uh county fiscal committee you know i am
trying to working with christie and
we're trying to look at different ways
that we could um within
cms's allowable methodologies to find
ways to to leverage our state spending
better um and we have
where they a year ago where they try to
cut back on it we found some ways to
offset what they were allowing for but
that's
that's a constant battle with us in
terms of you know
it's kind of like tax law they they find
different ways to to to pay less in the
as opposed to um you know a tax
situation but it's it's a there are
people who do this for a living every
so we're we're
we definitely want to make sure
our beneficiaries are cared for with
enough resources and so you know we're
in the game with them
okay thank you anything else folks
anybody else in the audience like
in that case i guess we're done as
unless somebody else says they need new
business their old business address
so do you understand mr chair
why the preterm scheduled
this meeting of division three so
quickly after the finance committee
reviewed the same bill that is she
expecting us to
vote this out so then return it to the
committee
that's not my understanding i understand
she's basically wanted us to get through
the work sessions today across the board
all the various divisions
we haven't voted out the other two which
are really important sp ones i mentioned
the medicaid dental
and the other we talked about when you
were gone so we need to vote those out
as well
and uh representative wallner asked that
we wait until uh at least representative
oregon is here and perhaps a replacement
for um
uh for uh
representative rogers thank you
should we show up
a support for the bill from what we've
learned so far
i'm fine with that if everybody else is
i don't want to you know care about that
can we support it so
i i can support it but i'm really
irritated this is the first i've heard
and just to continue on then do we all
support the the medicaid dental benefit
as amended to match
i do
yeah mr representative
yes and what was the other bill we
discussed last time
i know
that was a dental build it was the same
as 103.
so we all support that right
yeah 422 was it was this was the oh
no
i think the only bills in division three
are 412 and 422. there was another one
assigned to division three that was
reassigned to division one okay
all right so it sounds like we're all in
agreement at least tentatively on those
two uh bills
yes
okay
thanks for letting me sleep
you're
very welcome with that i'll uh close the
okay i guess sitting in the pilot seat
by the way
i'm going to go lay down here wait
business
hey kevin you got my email response yes
i did so did that give you a little bit
of better inside of what happened it was
not about this
okay
you